Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie, Avatar
The Last Airbender dropped a bunch of new trailers
and footage with a bunch of Easter eggs and references
to the original series. So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I will be doing episode videos
just like I did for the original Avatar series.
And just like The Legend of Korra, be a big flash.
In the past,
it's been a hot minute since I've done Avatar videos.
Let me know in the comments if you actually subscribed
to my channel back in the day
when we were actually doing that,
I think the original core series ended around 2014.
So it has been a long time.
there's a couple of trailers
they released, just starting with the Zuko trailer.
So in the trailer or across the entire trailer, he's
writing to someone.
I like to think that he's actually
writing to his mother, even though he has no idea
where his mother is.
part of the idea is that he's always wondered
what happened to her and doesn't
really find out until after the events of Avatar
The Last Airbender Book three.
It was a subject of the Avatar comic. The search.
Like literally he is searching for his mother because
he learns that she's still alive out there somewhere.
Probably one of the biggest questions in the fandom
before they release that comic book was
what happened to Zuko's mother
because you don't really get her story
in that part of Zuko's story
until he starts flashing back.
I could do like five videos.
Just talking about Zuko's
mother in the back story there.
So we'll get into that and in future bonus videos
when we actually start getting episodes.
but part of the idea in the trailer
is that they're using his letter
to also convey the story of the hundred year
war of the Fire nation against the air
nomads in his search for the avatar in present day.
when he says, We've been at war for a hundred years,
they flashback to the genocide of the Air Nomads.
They confirm that this person is his great grandfather,
Fire Lord Susan,
which is a change from the original TV show.
In the original TV show just ordered the hit on the air
Nomads Because he knew that after Roku died,
who he'd actually been friends with,
even though they became enemies eventually.
the next avatar will be born to the air nomads.
so he who's actually trying to end the line of avatars
and the resurrection of avatars
by killing all the air nomads, like,
if I kill them, then there can't be another avatar.
but at the time, at least in the original show,
unless they've changed this in present day, is that Aang
had actually already been born and he was 12 years old
when this attack is actually going down.
But he'd already become the avatar
the minute he was born.
they're couple scenes in the other trailer
where you see him with Monk Gyatso,
and you notice that he doesn't
have his air nomad tattoos yet.
so because they're showing us
the actual attack on the air.
Nomads like we'll get fire Lord Susan versus Monkey
also like a big fight scene between the two of them in
Aang will have already fled maybe they actually filmed
a new scene of him getting his Airbender tattoos
Speaking of Airbenders, a lot of people wondered
if this person here is actually Avatar Yangchen.
I don't think it is
only because I think this scene is meant to happen
during the fire
nation's attack on the Southern Air temple.
So I think she's just meant to be a random
female airbender because we're going to be
getting a bunch of Zuko flashback scenes,
but filmed as if they're happening in real time.
Like, we'll actually see how Zuko got his scar
instead of them just flashing back to it briefly.
when he quotes the line from Uncle Iroh
about the nature of fire
benders being expanding and consuming like fire itself.
That's the line from the original show.
they'll probably have that a lot
on the Netflix series like them
copying and pasting dialog from the original series.
then we get a little scene of Zuko
talking to his men on his ship about his banishment.
Just basically setting more context for him,
getting his start like the whole reason
why he was banished in the first place.
Because he dishonored his father, part of the reason
why there are so many memes
about Zuko trying to regain his honor during book
one of the original show
is because his father told him he could return home
if he captured the Avatar.
It would restore his honor.
Then this scene of Aang waking up freaking out.
Seems like it's right after he comes out of the ice.
Like he's remembering everything
that happened at the Southern Air Temple in the attack
like it was just yesterday.
we get a bigger scene of him meeting Sokka
and then eventually
Katara and explaining who he is, what he is.
They're couple scenes of Katara water
bending, a lot of people
because they heard about changes
that Netflix series made to the original show.
Were wondering if they made her
like a really good water bender when the series begins.
the way the actress talks about it,
Katara is still meant to be a beginner water bender,
but I think part of what the Netflix series has done is
they've sped the arcs up for the characters.
So she's a slightly better water bender than she was
at the beginning of the original series.
But I'm guessing they'll still have her
get her final lessons
like the really important learning
when they go back to the northern water tribe.
then we get a couple of dialog scenes of Grand Gran,
who's Sokka and Katara
as grandmother, who actually has a long history
with the Northern Water tribe.
She was actually born in the Northern Water tribe
and was supposed to marry Pocha,
the person who eventually teaches Katara
how to water bend.
the whole reason why she wound up
and why Katara in Sokka were eventually born in
the southern water tribe is because she fled before
she was supposed to marry Parker.
She just didn't want to be part
of the Northern Water tribe.
but in the southern water tribe,
she eventually befriended Hama who is the blood bender
that they run into eventually on the series,
the guitar eventually goes up against
She met their grandfather, eventually
their father was born and then they were born
part of the reason, though, why Katara isn't
that good of a water bender when the series picks up
is because there's not that many water benders,
if any, in the southern water tribe,
because most of them have been captured by the fire
nation and put in prisons, particularly Hama.
Then we get a brand new scene that wasn't in
the original series with Avatar Kyoshi at her stature.
It seems like
Aang is going to get a vision in a message from Avatar.
Kyoshi.
during the original series,
Kyoshi doesn't really become a character.
Like you can actually hear her talking to Aang or him
getting visions of her until a book
to one of the changes
the Netflix people said they made to
the original Avatar story is they sped the plot up
NG is supposed to learn that he has to go
to the northern water tribe to finish learning
how to water Ben from a master much, much sooner
than he did in the original series.
that might be what happens here at Avatar
Kyoshi statue.
It might be Kyoshi spirit that just speaks to him
and gives him the message.
You must go to the Northern Water
tribe Early on during book one.
Most of his interactions with previous
avatars are actually with Avatar Roku,
who gives him a lot of these messages.
So we'll see how they incorporate that
into the Netflix series.
Then we got a little more footage of this fight scene
with guitar in the Northern Water tribe.
This is confirmed Zuko.
So we get a confirms Zuko versus guitar.
If I then we get a much longer clip
with a bunch of behind the scenes
and a bunch of new characters
that they haven't featured in the previous trailers.
So this scene where they're doing interviews
with the executive producers like The Green
all around them is actually inside King Boogie's
Temple in Oamaru Green for Earth Kingdom.
Obviously,
we get a little more of Suki in the Kyoshi Warriors.
We actually see Snooki's mother later in this too.
I'll point her out.
this scene of Katara is her reciting her dialog
from the original animated intro scene line for line
four nations used to live in harmony,
but everything changed from the fire nation attacked.
there's another new scene of Jet.
He'll be a big character during season one.
He'll probably come back
at the beginning of season two, unless they change
some of the ways that Zuko and Iris
make it into the Earth kingdom in boxing.
Say, Because it looks like
there are scenes of them inside
what looks like Doomadgee,
which would be another big change
from the original series this you might recognize
is Tamlyn Tomita from Karate Kid.
She's done a bunch of other stuff.
She also came back for Cobra Kai
as that same character from Karate Kid.
She's playing Yukari, who's meant to be Sookie's
mother on Kyoshi Island.
In the original show, though,
you never actually meet Sookie's mother.
this scene of him bumping into the statue.
The owl is meant to be them doing the scene
from the original intro in live action.
But the funny thing about the original Avatar series
is that during those original episodes,
you never actually see him bump into the statue
that way during the episodes themselves.
He only does it in those intros.
The owl is meant to be a statue of one
shi tong the owl.
So maybe we'll get a reference to his library
during season one.
But in the original show
it didn't really appear until book two.
So I think it's going to be a while
before they actually go to the library itself.
Speaking of which, that was another big, tough episode.
We're probably not going to see Toph
till either like a post-credits scene, maybe
like a teaser for her character then really becoming
a main character during season two.
and it is surreal hearing Daniel Dae Kim talk regularly
about the world of Avatar while in his fire
Lord Ozai outfit.
He has a long history with Avatar
so you probably remember
he played
Asami, his father, Hiroshi Sato, during Legend of Korra
but he also starred during the original Avatar
The Last Airbender series.
he was also the voice of General
Fong in the Earth Kingdom during book two.
So maybe they'll have a joke about that.
but because that character didn't show up
until book two.
Maybe we won't see him till season two.
this market where Zuko and Aang are arguing
seems like it's actually no know
you just based on the architecture
in the greenery around that
like all the green coloration this would be another
really big change from the original series.
because Zuko eventually does bail on the Fire Nation
army with Ira.
But that didn't happen until a little bit later.
in after.
Zuko rescued NG wearing the blue spirit mask from his
Yao's prison, which we see in all the other trailers.
Both of them went their separate ways
and didn't really run into each other
until the big one finale in the Northern Water tribe.
they did eventually reunite inside the Earth Kingdom,
but that didn't happen till Book two.
Like way, way later in the story.
So we'll just have to see what goes on here, like what
causes them to actually meet each other inside.
Omar Shu like way, way earlier in the story.
and this scene of Ira looking like he's in Earth
Kingdom Robes also seems like it's in the same place.
You know, Masha, because they're trying to hide
the fact that there are fire benders.
part of the idea is the Earth kingdom
absolutely hates the fire nation.
So if they learned that they were fire benders,
they'd arrest them on the spot.
this is a really big storyline during book two.
Like they basically hid out in boxing, say,
just trying to pretend like they were normal people,
not fire benders.
there's a whole bunch of other footage here.
Like, I could go on for, like, another 30 minutes
just talking about all the Easter eggs and references
to the original series.
So they'll be a couple more bonus videos
before the series actually drops.
If you have any big questions about the characters
or some of the changes,
they may just write them below in the comments
and I'll try to address them
because it's a Super Bowl weekend
There's a whole bunch of trailers coming. Big Deadpool
3 Trailer
be sure to enable alerts for my channels
so you don't miss that
There was also a trailer for the Sonic Knuckles
spinoff series
It's a spinoff of Sonic 3
I'll try to do a video for that too,
in the next couple of days
Click here for all my other Avatar
The Last Airbender trailer
videos, and click here for that
brand new Sonic 3 trailer
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!